You know, I think
drop shadows-- they're
like the singletons
of the design world.
They're easy to make,
but as a result,
they can be overused
by people who
don't know what they're doing.
Guilty.
And therefore, it's kind of
trendy to make fun of them.
But when done
right, drop shadows
can be incredibly useful.
They can be a great way to
draw your user's attention
to the usable elements
on the screen,
and they can add a nice
tactile feel to your app.
And as you also
probably noticed,
they play a significant role
in Google's material design
guidelines.
So for us, applying shadows
in the correct manner
is important.
Not just from a
design standpoint,
but from an engineering
standpoint as well.
You see, drop shadows
can also be expensive.
Do them wrong, and you can
waste precious CPU cycles.
But if you do them
right, your app
can still look nice while
keeping that silky smooth frame
rate.
Let's find out how on this
episode of "Route 85."
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So, I want to start by
thanking Jeremy Goldberg, a UX
designer working on
the Google app for iOS
for providing me with all
this great information.
Thanks, Jeremy.
Now, there are many ways
to draw shadows on iOS,
each with its own advantages
and disadvantages.
But today, we're going
to look at two of them.
First up-- drawing shadows
in a core animation layer.
Now, this method is great
because it's simple.
You just define all
your shadow properties
in code, which also means that
tweaking or messing with them
later is simply a matter
of adjusting a few numbers.
Plus, it's easy to change
your shadow dynamically
if that's the kind
of thing you're into.
Here, for instance,
you can see that I'm
animating the shape of my view
and the offset of my shadow,
all in code, and iOS is drawing
the shadow appropriately
in real time.
Pretty neat, huh?
Now, you can access the
CALayer of any UIView
by accessing its layer
property, just like so.
Then adding a shadow
is simply a matter
of adding a shadow radius,
offset, color, and an opacity.
I'm not going to go into
too much detail around these
since you can probably
figure them out on your own,
but I do encourage
you to play around
with them, if for no other
reason than it's kind of fun.
So all this is great, but
drawing a shadow in a CALayer
can be slow.
And if you have
a lot of elements
onscreen with a
lot of shadows, it
can really hurt
your performance.
So what can you do?
Well, one tip is
to use Bezier paths
to define your shadow's shape.
You see, iOS is calculating
the shape of your view
on the fly in order to
determine its shadow.
This does let you do
really cool things,
like have your
UIImageView include
an image with transparency.
IOS will accurately
draw the shadow
based on the opaque
parts of this image.
Pretty neat, huh?
But this process does
require some work.
And if your view
is, say, a square,
all this calculation
is really unnecessary.
Yeah, you know, iOS,
I could have told you
that my view is a square.
In fact, I think I will.
You see, you can explicitly
define your shadow's shape
by using a Bezier path.
To do this, first create
a CGPath ref to represent
your shadow, and you can do this
using any Bezier path drawing
code, but probably drawing
a rectangle is a good start.
Then set your path reference
as the shadowPath property
of your CALayer.
All your other code can
be the same as before.
You've just short-circuited
the very expensive step
of having iOS calculate
the shape of your shadow.
Incidentally, this
also means you
can create a shadow that's not
the same shape as your view.
Why would you ever
want to do this?
Well, you probably never
actually want to do this.
This is weird, but there
are some more practical
applications.
For instance, adding
a curve shadow
underneath a square image
gives it that curved paper look
without your having to actually
warp anything in your view.
And you can go with
convex here or concave,
and they both look kind of nice.
If you had an oval shadow
underneath your view,
you can give it
a, hey, my object
is standing up in 3D
space over a floor
kind of look, which is cool.
And if you have a complicated
shape that would normally
use a complicated shadow-- like,
say, this postage stamp image--
you can give it a simple shadow
instead, like this rectangle,
and greatly simplify
your rendering.
Now, another trick you
could try, with caution,
is to rasterize your layer.
Doing so takes a
snapshot of your layer,
including its shadow, as
a bitmap and caches it.
Which means iOS won't have to
recalculate at every frame.
It's really easy to do, just set
your CALayers shouldRasterize
property to true,
or, yes, depending.
But you need to be careful here.
Rasterizing a layer means your
device is doing extra work
copying your layer to memory.
It also means
you're using up some
of that precious,
precious memory.
And so if the
contents of your layer
change on a regular
basis, you're
going to be doing more
work turning more memory,
and this technique could
backfire on you spectacularly.
And I will say
that in practice, I
found that Google tends to not
use this technique as often
as the Bezier path one.
But if you have a view where
the content doesn't change
but the view itself
animates-- maybe you
have items in a
UICollectionView or you
think a bouncing logo is a good
idea for some reason-- those
might be good candidates
for rasterization.
Just be sure to use the core
animation instrument in Xcode
to confirm that it's giving
you the performance boost
that you are expecting.
But if none of these
techniques work
for you-- say you've got a
really big view with a really
big shadow-- well, then it's
time to break out the big guns
and build your shadow
as a graphic asset.
See, the theory behind
this is that you
create an image to
represent your view's shadow
and 9-slice it for easy scaling.
Now, if you're not
familiar with the concept
of 9-slicing an
image, it basically
means you would take
an image like this one
and slice it in a tic-tac-toe
pattern, like this.
Now, if you were to
resize this image,
those corners would
stay unchanged.
But you can see
the side sections--
they stretch vertically.
These top and bottom sections
will stretch horizontally.
And the center can stretch
in both dimensions.
And this allows you to resize
your image in such a way
that nothing looks too
stretched out or funky.
People often use this technique
in creating resizable buttons
or dialog boxes, but it can
also be used for shadows.
Neat, huh?
You can see where
we're going with this.
Now, there are two ways
you can create this image.
One-- create it using a
tool like Photoshop, Sketch,
whatever, and
export it as a file
and then just import it
into your Xcode project.
The other way is you can create
a UIImage directly in code.
Turns out this is pretty easy
to do since CGContext lets
you draw with a drop shadow.
Either way, you want to end up
with a fairly small image that
is ready for 9-slicing.
Now, to 9-slice an
image, you're going
to call the UIImage resizable
image with cap insets,
and this basically tells
iOS where your slices are
for resizing purposes.
Oh, and do make sure that
you set your resizing mode
to stretch-- that's important.
Then you just change the
frame of your shadow image,
and iOS will resize it
based on these cap insets
to scale everything in
a nice 9-sliced way.
Add this view as a
subview to your content,
iOS scales it, and
ta-da, you've got
yourself a nice little shadow.
Now, this technique does
have a couple of drawbacks.
One-- it really only works on
rectangles, rounded rectangles,
or other shapes that work well
with 9-scaling, or 9-slicing.
It doesn't work so well with
stars or irregular shapes.
Two-- you have now complicated
your view hierarchy
because you've added a
new subview everywhere
to represent your shadow,
and that can sometimes
get a little messy.
And three-- you've either
added more process to your app
if you're generating your
shadow using graphics tool,
or more code to
your app if you're
drawing your shadow in code
which means there are more
places where things
can go wrong.
But if you have a lot of large
views with large shadows,
and you're smart about
reusing this code,
it's probably worth
the trade-off.
At least for us, we think it is.
If you look at the
Google app on iOS
and look at either the Google
Now cards or our recent pages
list, these are all examples
of views that have shadows
supplied using images.
So these are just a handful of
tricks we use to draw shadows.
Do you have your own?
Feel free to share them
in the comments below,
and I'll read them.
Thanks again for watching.
So did you find this useful?
If so, click here
to see more videos
from "Route 85," our show
for you iOS developers.
And until next time, dear
viewers, who knows what evil
lurks in the hearts of men.
The-- actually these days, it's
probably the incognito mode
guy.
He's seen some stuff
you wouldn't believe.
It's a good thing you
can't talk, buddy.
All right, I'll
see you all later.
[MUSIC PLAYING]